[Music]
the original gravity rush had many
positive qualities but cat it's upbeat
and unusually skilled hero was the
reason to play the game with the ability
to control her center of gravity you
could walk on walls and ceilings and
most important of all fly through a
magnificent floating city in the clouds
the unusual gravity based nature of cats
powers made the age-old concept of
flight feel fresh and managed to carry
the otherwise imaginative yet
underdeveloped adventure with untapped
potential and numerous unanswered
questions by the end gravity rush felt
like it needed a sequel to finish its
tale more than just a simple follow-up
gravity rush to exceeds expectations by
going above and beyond the original game
filling in gaps while simultaneously
telling a new story it also crucially
doubles down on depth and scale
significantly increasing the scope of
the adventure and the number of optional
missions like the first game you spend
most of your time peacefully flying
around looking for key items and
characters to move the story along but
when alien like nivi enemies appear cat
turns full action super here with the
ability to magically throw inanimate
objects cat can pick off small enemies
or weaken large brutes from a distance
but you typically rely on her kick
abilities to get the job done fighting
in midair and gravity rush to feels a
lot like the first game exciting and
unusual and at the mercy of the camera
most enemies have sensitive red orbs on
their body and while you are required to
target them to inflict damage there are
built-in aiming assists that make your
life a little bit easy
cats stories reestablished months after
the conclusion of the first game and you
spend quite a bit of time in new
locations before reconnecting with her
past cat will have to navigate a
slave-like existence at a mining camp
without her powers in the beginning and
while this section does feel a little
deflating given that cats powers are the
first thing you want to play with out of
the gate it thankfully doesn't last too
long
at best the intro helps set up the new
conflict and a fresh cast of characters
and after you break out of the intro
you're brought to a divided society
where the rich live in opulence above
the clouds and the poor try to scrape by
an existence below the examinations of
these topics aren't revelatory or
groundbreaking gravity rush to love
silver linings but they lend a small
amount of relatability to the
otherworldly Rome
with over 20 episodes and 40
side-missions boredom is rarely an issue
gravity rush to goes to great lengths to
connect side missions back to the main
story revealing new facets of seemingly
minor characters that enhance your
understanding of their position in
society and thus your perspective of the
bigger picture the only types of
missions that wear thin are those that
rely on basic stealth rules sometimes
you have to sneak around a base of
soldiers and avoid their sight lines
while you make for a key location or you
may trail a suspicious character to
gather Intel either way these missions
by and large fail to leverage the game's
greatest strengths missions aside simply
flying around the world as a captivating
experience in its own ring both for the
thrilling sense of flight and for the
beauty of your surroundings the world
pops with color and character building
on the first game strong ghibli ask
visuals and basic exploration is once
again made more rewarding by the
hundreds of gems used for ability
upgrades strewn across the map
[Music]
gravity rush to also incentivizes casual
exploration by introducing emergent
events generated by other people playing
the game on a somewhat regular basis
notifications pop up when you're flying
to and fro indicating a nearby treasure
hunt
you're then given a chance to examine a
photo of the relevant location and
pinpoint landmarks to zero in on the
treasure chest
this proves as a fun diversion that
tests your observation and navigation
skills in new ways and if you generate a
photo that leads to another player
finding treasure you eventually receive
a small reward for your work it is a
small touch but treasure hunts also
reinforce the feeling that you're a part
of a world that operates independently
of your adventure befitting the new
large and lively open-world
[Music]
after more than a dozen hours of helping
the poor supporting your friends and
uncovering corruption at the highest
levels of government
gravity rush to concludes its new story
before revisiting Kats origin story in
the final act you discover the answers
to the biggest mysteries laid out in
both games and you have to do a little
detective work at first to get the ball
rolling but once you find the path
forward gravity rush to delivers a
series of exciting over-the-top boss
battles and scenes that delve into Kats
pre gravity rush past in effect gravity
rush to fulfills the needs of both the
sequel and a prequel and manages to tell
a new and interesting story in between
while it's disappointing to see the
camera issues appear during battle from
time to time
gravity rush to otherwise excels in
almost every other respect making its
predecessors seem quaint by comparison
it's easily one of the best video game
sequels in recent memory and an
adventure that's truly worthy of its
excellent lead character
Oh
[Music]